welcome back did you know there's a
significant connection between coba 19
and type 2 diabetes
there's a company that you that can help
you reverse this risk and stop your
diabetes
dr hockey welcome to las vegas now it's
great to be here thanks
of course now you are the founder of
help your diabetes so let's just start
with
what the connection is between type 2
diabetes and what we're all dealing with
right now
covet 19. yeah well the cdc says that 94
of anybody who dies from covid has at
least one
underlying health condition and one of
the most common underlying health
conditions is type 2 diabetes
so it's really important for people who
have type 2 diabetes that try to reverse
it
so it can prevent them from having a
severe complication from cove but even
if they've got the vaccine by the way
now some people might not know that type
2 diabetes is reversible so let's
explain that
yeah it's 100 reversible we have the
only patented system in the world that
reverses
type 2 diabetes and we actually
guarantee results
so people follow our program if there's
if they're not off all their diabetic
meds at the end
they get 100 refund plus 500 just for
trying it
so yeah it can definitely be reversed
when you change your lifestyle the right
way
that is incredible and i understand you
have a testimonial you want to share who
are we who
are we are so this is uh paul martin's
he's had a great success
this is just one of the thousands of
people who've gone through a program
so he's going to kind of share his
success story i've been a diabetic
at least 12 or 13 years i was injecting
myself with basal insulin
levomir at between 20 and 40 units a day
i was taking 500 milligrams
of metformin twice a day
approximately four months later i was
off all of my medication
off of the basal insulin off of the
metformin
my blood sugar numbers had dropped they
have consistently
stayed right around the 100 level
my a1c measurement of
blood sugar when i started was around
7.5 or 7.6 when it was last
measured it was at 5.6
which is no longer
diabetic and so it's been able to be
reversed
under the help your diabetes program how
do people find more information
about the program yeah so right now they
can actually register for a
comprehensive
diabetes reversal consultation with me
so
that includes a diabetes reversal
training video presentation
they get a diabetes score and a
comprehensive diabetes assessment and a
plan
and so the normal fee for that is 150
the first thirty people that go
to the website actually get it for
thirty seven dollars only so you can go
to stopyourdiabetesnow.com
that's stoppedyourdiabetesnow.com they
can register there
wow thank you so much dr hawkins this is
amazing work that you're doing
head to stopyourdiabetesnow.com and
check out their special offer a
comprehensive diabetes reversal
consultation
which includes video training a diabetes
reversal score
reversal assessment and customized plan
las vegas now we'll be right back